Oh nobody's here what happened tell me I
am helping really I'm taking the video
YouTube's more important and neither of
us are hungry I'm going for dinner me as
a rule breaker yeah sure you got to do
things that are different sometimes and
our outside your comfort zone I'm gonna
name this bat Nina Nina I know you're
gonna say that okay Nina the bat good
morning I on slept for four games at
night when we have to get up in six
thirty-first la power base and why
others you in RBIs okay we're going to
explore prediction good videos
Nina's very excited we just arrived
we're walking and it's raining on us
yeah he was worried about her makeup
five dollars each or total total all
right let's do it where's the Sun who's
Barbados but waiting for the Sun think
is going shopping so find out that
impressive shopping we're going back to
the main area it's raining on us
we film some videos for the youtube
channel and now we're going to grab a
quick bite to eat at the most famous
restaurant in Barbados the waterfront
cafe where you have to try the flying
fish sandwich so we're going to see what
that's all about and then continue our
adventure Nina's getting on her Wi-Fi so
she can transfer the videos we just made
to Christina on top box while we eat so
it can be edited and put up for you guys
enjoy the other thing that I want to do
is I have all my Evernote files on the
iPad here which can be a little
cumbersome to carry around so I want to
transfer everything over to my phone on
Evernote so that I can just put it in my
pocket go pro in one pocket phone in the
other everything I need to be able to
finish our travel plans
really I'm taking the video YouTube's
more important okay we have our what are
these fish cakes meaning oh hello young
and we have the world famous flying fish
sandwich doctor it's gonna put the hot
sauce on oh she said watch out for that
one yeah watch out oh here comes big
fight with the hot sauce yeah are you
gonna start crying food is just ok not
even actually think probably beyond
lower than okay
yeah not very good actually did we came
on a bad day I don't know
okay we're going to get some water and
continue to explore find a way to the
Chado village for to the beach we'll see
what we find easy
so we've been walking and walking and
walking Nina's getting tired we've been
walking and we're finally here at the
beach our own little piece of paradise
okay well that was awesome and then when
I got in the water to film it was so
warm it's one of the warmest beach water
that I've been in that I forced me to
the come in with me and then I pulled
her in with my dress on so I'm little
wet but it was fun right it's a
different experience you got to do
things that are different sometimes an
hour outside your comfort zone and that
challenge each other ok we're going to
maybe check out a rum factory and then
head back to the cruise I'm getting
hungry ok so far so good really relaxing
I feel real up refreshed and relaxed
look at my shoes you can see the eyes of
her socks through the shoes Nina has a
devious plan we're not to bring alcohol
on the cruise ships we're going to empty
out above the water it's a wonder finish
it
Nina died today use a rule breaker yeah
sure all right we're back it's not a
shower every sixpack we go yeah pretty
event in fact i was a bit of a smiley
person yeah oh my gosh I got a headache
Oh a bit of a smelly person we are going
to have some food snack can we have
dinner soon what was the cups nice oh I
owe for Nina's drinks right especially
what does mean is light snack look like
yummy chicken soup just after what does
Evans like snack look like we got pizza
we got pasta rooster cheese sauce and
extra cheese and my shut my mouth is
watering as I'm saying this I wrapped
the bobbing and some beef stew and two
pieces of cheese underneath the beef
cheese pizzas time to eat oh she's
stealing it she's stealing before I even
had a fight that's not cool that's not
cool it's not cool man and so after that
sack we went back for seconds Nina
filled up her plate
it was huge
and then we went back to the room passed
out we didn't sleep relax i guess relax
I'm feeling a little Spacey I'm not have
enough sleep before I get two hours not
enough sleep and neither of us are
hungry I'm going for dinner so Nina's
gonna order another three appetizers
like last night no and I might have to
carry her to the room over my shoulder
we're in a dress so that's not good all
right in the time Nina stony not she
wants to go to europe in august or
September we're in your what what do you
want to go in here anyway breathe
twisting we'll see what happens okay
good morning the last thing we filmed
last night was the food to room back to
the cabin watchin TV and passed out I
passed that I had almost eight hours
sleep but when I woke up to Nina's alarm
I didn't know where I figured so we are
in st. Lucia today I think it's creamy
it's raining a little bit there were
crazy sirens going off when we got off
the boat lovely interesting we're gonna
see what we can do Felicia here's Nina
he's inspired by this tree with insanely
huge fruit we don't know what kind of
fruit that is if anybody knows what kind
of fruit this is leaving the comments
below and nina's will love to hear from
you
we put the boat cruise that's going to
take us to a bunch of places that we are
excited to see
either going to have the switch to the
water cover on the camera so that we can
ruin but has really bad audio so you
won't hear from us or wildly of cs
okay back on the boat ready for dinner
we had a fun time
irritated reporters are gonna get some
hydrocortisone cream we thought it'd be
better to go in time but room tour today
his opener
we learned when we only knew this photo
we reaffirm that we don't like going
through tours because they're just too
slow go ended up not seeing everything
because art are two words too slow and
let's go people so we can't do tours
anymore what on the boat ride back we
also had some interesting life
discussions about big plans where we
want to go other things in our life that
we want to plan that we're not talking
about my youtube channel yeah so that's
exciting when you go away it's a good
chance to think about things in my life
right yeah i mean is the one on my
family
too boring for her he's more active
vacation okay did a time Oh nobody's
here what happened is it at six o'clock